NARRATOR: Power is
not a birth right.
It's earned with teeth,
and claws,
and sacrifice.
Savagery wins wars.
If you're strong
enough to seize it,
this new kingdom
will be yours.
For generations kings
and queens have reigned
well over Mombo.
A bountiful Eden
far south of Savute.
But they now face the greatest
threat to their long rule.
A rebel army is
rising from the shadows.
Led by Mmamotse,
commander of the damned.
The abundant land
fuels her savage ranks.
She now has enough soldiers
to lay siege to the kingdom.
No more hiding
in the darkness,
eating scraps.
Mmamotse wants
the lion's share.
She wants it all.
She wants the throne.
The king had nothing
to fear until now.
The tide is turning.
But reigning queens do
not surrender lightly.
Perhaps a truce?
Only a fool could
believe such nonsense.
Time to reveal the full
force of her hidden army.
(growling).
(hyenas laughing).
Mmamotse sets her unstoppable
virus loose on Eden.
Her new regime feeds
on fear and violence.
You will all now bow to me.
Under Mmamotse's
wretched reign,
life in the kingdom is
about to change for everyone.
Pula rules the forest.
The beating
heart of the realm.
Her torn ear, just one of
a decade's worth of scars.
From battles fought,
and battles won.
Not born into royalty, Pula
works hard for her dominion.
But her success is
marred by tragedy.
She has only one
surviving heir.
This season could be her final
chance to further her legacy.
She will be strong and ready.
The advantage of high
position in paradise,
there's always a
seat at the high table.
(growling, gazelle groans).
Sheer will earns this
humble-born her wealth.
A firm grip
ensures she keeps it.
Hide your riches and eat fast.
Thieves are everywhere.
Every bite makes
Pula stronger.
But the truly wise
know when to yield.
(hyenas laughing).
Let the tyrants
take their tax.
There's plenty more
where that came from.
But dark times are coming.
NARRATOR: Shattered
monarchs drift in
fragments of their
former prides.
But three stubborn warriors
remain in the promised land.
Led by Sega with
only half a tail.
The sisters of the
Matahta pride are stranded.
Their family is scattered.
But their will is
far from broken.
Sega must rebuild her
pride from the ground up.
One little piggy at a time.
She has her own hidden secret.
Six young heirs.
Future kings and queens.
The foundations
of a new empire.
Her sisters share the burden.
And the babysitting.
A relentless
onslaught of tiny teeth.
(meowing).
Their hunger bodes well
for the pride's fortunes,
if Sega can keep them alive
and teach them some manners.
(meowing).
This ravenous horde will
one day rule the kingdom.
The balance of power
can shift in an instant.
But there's always one
who swaggers with ease
through the wreckage.
Blue Eyes, the most
charming leopard in the realm.
He's making his rounds,
staking his claims.
Quite the perfect specimen.
(snorting, squealing).
He didn't really feel
like warthog anyway.
Blue Eyes is not
here for food.
He's here for Pula.
She only has eyes for him.
Vanity aside,
he is proud and strong
and Pula's best chance
to further her bloodline.
♪ ♪
With him by her side,
her legacy could last for
generations to come.
The young are the future.
Sega's pride grows
stronger every day.
These cubs will be warriors.
But for now, they depend on
their mothers for everything.
Protect them at all costs.
Inside their creche,
the world is safe.
But there's always one
born bolder than the rest.
Adventure lures the
curious cub away from
his mother's cautious eye.
He's yet to learn the
dangers of the wild.
An innocent spirit
in a ruthless world.
♪ ♪
NARRATOR: A mother's
intuition is seldom wrong.
A head count confirms
one cub is missing.
Sega issues a call to arms.
Where is he?
(roaring).
Search as they may,
their efforts are in vain.
Blue Eyes has seen to that.
A mother's grief
means nothing to him.
It's just an easy meal
and one less future rival.
Sega has not only lost
a valuable soldier,
but a son.
(thunder).
Rain cannot
cleanse a wicked world.
But here in Mombo it
does reset the game.
In this kingdom,
water is the real power.
The new season delivers
all Pula ever wanted.
(meowing).
This is Motshidi.
Welcome to the
world, my little one.
Pula's destiny now rests
on your tiny shoulders.
Blue Eyes is not
to be trusted.
He's killed his
own cubs before.
Pula cannot risk
his dark side again.
Only he knows why he
would kill his own.
NARRATOR: Pula has got what
she needed from Blue Eyes.
Now she must protect
her investment.
Leave us alone!
You are no longer welcome.
Motshidi is all
that matters now.
Keep her safe, Pula.
Carry her gently from
her violent father.
From everyone, until
she can hold her own.
Mmamotse's reign
begins with chaos.
Her minions patrol every
corner of the kingdom.
The orders are simple.
No one is above her rule.
Everyone will pay a price.
Most would cower in the
presence of this dragon.
But Mmamotse sees
only opportunity.
Use the beast.
Let him do the dirty work.
(gazelle groaning).
Now take our share.
Even dragons will
serve the tyrant.
She will win this tug of war
to get ahead.
There is always more to steal,
until she conquers everyone.
♪ ♪
NARRATOR: The Matahta pride's
loss hardens their resolve.
The sisters nurture
their surviving cubs.
One day they will take
on tyrants together.
But until then, they
will trust no one.
A drifting vagabond, out
of place in the new regime.
Sega does not know
him nor his intentions.
He could offer protection,
perhaps even a quick
path to the throne.
But at what price?
He could kill all
their remaining cubs.
The sisters can't
risk losing another.
(roaring).
Their decision is clear.
But the wounded hopeful
still begs for acceptance.
He needs them more
than they need him.
But Sega cannot
take the chance.
Their new dynasty is
far too important.
These warrior sisters will build
their empire on their own.
(birds chirping).
Motshidi does not have the
benefit of the queen's guard.
But she does have a
devoted role model.
Pula is her protector.
Her provider.
She will teach her
everything she needs to know.
Motshidi already
shares her mother's spirit.
Curious and bold.
A young assassin eager to
explore her forest world.
(chirping, meowing).
She has so much to learn.
Savor these
precious moments, Pula.
Danger is only
ever a footfall away.
NARRATOR: The single
hyena is a very bad omen.
Where there's one,
there are always more.
Pula knows the
kingdom's tyrants.
But this is Motshidi's
first encounter.
They will be here soon.
Quick! Hide!
Your tyrant queen may
think herself a royal.
But you are a wretched spy.
We still own the forest.
♪ ♪
Where are you, little one?
Did I teach you well?
Pula is wise and strong.
A self-made noble
who earns her power.
If Motshidi follows
her mother's footsteps,
one day she will
inherit this world.
(elephants rumbling).
But the walls are closing in.
Flood waters
surround the kingdom,
now just an island in
Botswana's great delta.
(screaming).
The realm welcomes a new cat.
This is no place for
a cheetah, not now.
Lured in by the promise of
plenty to feed her three cubs.
This place certainly seems
like heaven to this family.
But little does she know,
Mmamotse's rotten
clan sees everything.
This land is no Eden
for anyone but them.
The hostile welcome
exposes her horrible mistake.
This young mother has
led her family into hell.
Now they're trapped on an
island ruled by tyrants.
But if she navigates
this nightmare,
she could stake her own
claim to the Savage Kingdom.
Captioned by Cotter
Captioning Services.